[Applause]
[Music]
my name's James I started a Coffee
Roasting Company in 2002 I was thinking
while I was back in the green room dead
in 2002 what percentage of the audience
in 2002 was waiting for their mom to
pick them up at soccer practice is that
80% maybe anyway I was a grown up in
2002 I didn't have a great inspired idea
what to call my company so there was an
interesting and maybe apocryphal a side
note in the history of European coffee
there's a heroic and romantic story of
the founding of central Europe's first
coffee house in 1683 so I always a
sucker for the heroic and the romantic I
named my company after der blaue and
flashin but in English hello peanut my
three year old just blew me a kiss
sorry where was I so I called it the
Blue Bottle um that that's the logo up
there so a little bit about me on paper
my qualifications or I think are
particularly maybe spectacularly or
supremely unsuitable for a career in
retail entrepreneurship I have a
bachelor's degree in philosophy and a
master's degree in clarinet performance
thank you very much and in in my script
I have after that I have pause for
snickering so I'm glad I'm glad I wrote
that I didn't just go right into it so
which means I don't have the usual
things that which usually cause somebody
to be up here talking to you I don't
have a degree in engineering or MBA I
didn't work for a VC
or a place like McKinsey where they know
everything or basically any prior
knowledge of the world of Commerce what
I had was a reflexive desire for
something that I could understand a
model of Commerce that even I could
understand and so I had to create a very
simple business fortunately I was a
farmers market shopper and that was a
model of commerce that I could
understand it's quite simple if you
haven't been to a farmers market what
you do is there's like people that have
stuff that they've made and you give the
money for that stuff they give you the
thing that they've made and then you
repeat it the next week and even I could
understand that so in 2002 I had two
credit cards the limits were not very
high and I had around twenty thousand
dollars in savings which seemed like all
the money in the world and I signed a
lease in in your materials that says 86
square feet it was actually a 186 square
feet so I signed a lease in a very small
Coffee Roasting space about that big I
bought a used roaster for $5,000 and and
then went to work in farmers markets and
now after successful rounds of funding
led by the likes of true ventures Index
Ventures Google Ventures fidelity we
have Blue Bottle has 60 or so not quite
60 cafes in the US and Japan and last
October there we sold a controlling
interest in Blue Bottle to the largest
food company in the world which is
Nestle so I wasn't sure what kind of
reaction I was going to get actually
after that I have any anyway I I won't
tell you what my notes were in the
script after that so I came to coffee as
a hobbyist I used to roast coffee very
crudely in a perforator baking sheet and
my oven my home oven and it would fill
the apartment with smoke but you know
but but it was very interesting at those
times in the late nineties
there's literally no place I could go in
San Francisco to get a bag of coffee
with a roast date stamped on it and this
idea that of coffee freshness was
something I thought was blindingly
obvious and simultaneously widely
overlooked so this idea that let's see
if I hit the right button Oh Marcel
Proust that's when I started that's the
idea that was basically the premise of
Blue Bottle coffee company coffee is
fresh fruit after roasting coffees
flavors develop they mature they get to
this peak of freshness and then begins
the inevitable decline that's depressing
and familiar but in the late 90s you
know as I said I couldn't find anybody
who were talking about this this idea of
coffee being a fresh food so and this
was also at the time before the internet
was taking the joy out of these personal
discoveries so I thought this idea
belonged to me and to me alone so this
idea that coffee is a fresh food is is
basically the premise the the
foundational idea the business plan you
could say of bluebottle and so how did
this inform the decision subsequently
that I took to make Blue Bottle coffee a
bigger thing so having the idea of
coffee being fresh food led me to be
very protective of this thing this this
thing called coffee it seemed very
simple I wanted to know that coffee was
this evanescent fragile delicious and
special thing that didn't need heavy
roasting it didn't need flavors so when
we opened our first kiosk in Hayes
Valley in 2005 on Linden Street I didn't
realize that the protective gestures I
made around this product were very
unusual for that time I was just doing
what I thought I had to do so no snow
sizes no flavors every drink ground and
prepared to order every milk drink
steamed to order I was interested in a
very pure experience of coffee
as pure as I could get and at the time
the number oh there's farmers market at
the time the number of cafes that were
doing that in California was exactly
zero so once that became so also with
the kiosk architectural II I could only
afford this little space in a garage so
it's like having that simplification
imposed on me it I was able to avoid the
tropes of cafe design at that time so
comfy couches messy couches bulletin
boards like all kind of the the messy
tropes of cafe design in the late 90s I
didn't have the money to do it
so it let me be very simple and people
really responded except for one thing
there's a notion of being protective of
the product led to some unfortunate
experiences for our guests who weren't
in as invested in coffee as we were so
being protective led to some bad
experiences unfortunately this isn't
from one of our cafes this is widely
shared on the internet a list of rules
that people were asked to guests we're
actually asked to observe at a cafe in
Memphis I think so fortunately in 2008
Gramercy Tavern asked us to provide
coffee for the restaurant Gramercy
Tavern is a kind of at the pinnacle of
New York City dining and it was known
for its deeply entrenched culture of
graciousness I spent about a week there
and the realization came to me that our
product wasn't coffee exactly our
product was the way a guest felt while
they were drinking our coffee in our
cafes that was a product and once that
became clear to me it freed me to really
delve into the mechanics of pleasure as
it relates to coffee and that's when
Blue Bottle fortunately was starting to
grow quite a bit at that time we were
adding cafes and I was hiring a lot of
employees so I needed a way to
encapsulate this idea of coffee being an
experience this pleasure being an
experience not just this absolute notion
of what's in the cup
so around that time I was asked to come
up with a mission statement and that I
failed at I wasn't able to provide a
mission statement and as I was walking
to the meeting to apologize for not
producing this mission statement I
realized that I didn't need a mission
statement I needed three words three
words that encapsulated what I wanted to
do and that was deliciousness
hospitality and sustainability so those
three words kind of ran Blue Bottle for
the next ten or twelve years and because
of the purity of those three words the
simplicity any time we told an employee
those three words they would remember it
right off the bat today we didn't need a
lot of materials and it was a way of
having a conversation with the people we
were working with so we could prioritize
this experience based on on those three
things and every new cafe was then an
opportunity to see how much could be
stripped away to showcase those three
words I realized that the more
unnecessary distractions could be
stripped away what remained would be
more memorable so for the last ten years
or so the purpose of our approach to
cafe design was a subtractive one to
remove obstacles from a primary to
experience that we needed our guests to
have and that primary experience was
this and that's only that a delicious
coffee served by a hospitable coffee
professional and we could train for that
we could strip away everything so that
was the only thing that remained or we
could try everything else was a
distraction so we built cafes for a few
years raised some money built some more
cafes and then I was worried about one
part of our business which was starting
to seem like a distraction one of the
dirty little secrets of the specialty
coffee industry is that the vast
majority of roaster retailers revenue is
in wholesale coffee and wholesale coffee
means when you sell beans not to a guest
in a cafe that you own and operate but
you sell beans to a restaurant or cafe
operator and have them
make the drinks for your guests you
can't you can't have the same amount of
control so around a few years ago I was
walking past a cafe and across the
street was a wholesale a wholesale
account of that that roaster retailer
and they said proudly serving as
wholesale accounts do and then they
mentioned the roaster retailers name and
everything was fine it looked fine
except they'd misspelled the roaster
retailers name and I realized that was
the essential problem of the wholesale
coffee business is that you can't force
somebody to care and if they weren't
willing to care it showed in the cup and
we got the blame so a few years ago we
made the very difficult decision to walk
away from 30% of our revenue and here I
have in the my script pause for gasps I
don't know didn't hear enough gasps I
think ah there I did that um so you know
why did we do that because if we really
believed in our product that meant we
wanted to take responsibility for it if
we really wanted to simplify the
experience and make it crystal clear
whose responsibility it was we had to
take responsibility for our own coffees
being served in our own cafe so and
wholesale became an obstacle for our
guests enjoyment and a distraction for
our business and that was a moment which
kind of crystallized an intuition into a
thought and the thought goes I think
something like this building value in
building revenue are two very different
things this is is me realizing this
after the fact but there at many points
at Blue Bottle coffee I've made
decisions just intuitively that have
been not about building revenue they've
been more about building value of
bluebottle and walking away from
wholesale was definitely one of those a
few other decisions like that that we
made Oh
building revenue is additive you you're
sort of in search of this these new
sources but building value is
subtractive
my opinion your your getting rid of
things your jettisoning things that
aren't important so what remains becomes
much more important becomes the the
singular focus in my mind and our guests
is mind so a few more things about how
we were able to think subtractive lis in
that way in order to build value is when
we offered that's the right the wrong
order but we built some as expensive
pastry kitchens and instead of using
wholesale baked goods and if we would
have used wholesale baked goods that
meant we could have built revenue faster
because we weren't investing in kitchens
but we took responsibility for our
products and we built some kitchens we
made some really delicious cookies we
made a decision to shorten the shelf
life on our bottled product it made it
much more delicious
we could have sold more we could have
gotten more revenue if it sat on store
shelves longer but we chose to make it
more delicious and that actually ended
up making a lot more attention for us
and then lastly we avoided joint venture
partners we avoided licenses when we
moved to Japan and opened a few years
ago and because we got to make our own
decisions we didn't have a licensed
partner telling us what we should or
should not do
and we made some kind of very strange
decisions about real estate and ignored
a lot of people's advice about how to
change our offerings in Tokyo and that
ended up I don't know if you can tell on
that slide but it was very busy for for
opening it was really busy and it's
still quite busy and we're opening a lot
of cafes wholly owned by Blue Bottle
coffee now and it's been more successful
than and just more interesting than a
more bloodless relationship with a JV
partnership could have been so taking
things away subtracting being more
essentialist
has worked really well for me and Blue
Bottle coffee over the last 16 years
because it has helped me staying focus
on the things that remain what remains
is by definition
what's most important but I've always
had anxieties about the future so my
central anxiety about the future of Blue
Bottle today has basically always been
my anxiety about Blue Bottle which is
are we going to be able to carve away
the things which should not be there and
continue to improve am I going to be
able to improve in my ability to imagine
cafes and coffee and the pleasure that
can be had for out of both and I find
myself more and more apprehensive in
that in the pursuit of scale my will to
work on these mysteries and the problems
I've been fascinated by for 16 years has
been eaten away by my own increasing
comfort and the knife-edge of my
intellect and desire for improvement has
been dulled by success and habit so I
take some consolation in a passage by
that connoisseur of anxiety Soren
Kierkegaard and I apply the idea of
vertiginous freedom to my anxious
thoughts much in the way that bactine is
applied to an open wound so thank you
very much everybody
enjoy your beer
[Applause]
you